منظومه صواريخ يارس المتطوره او كما يطلق
عليها حلف شمال الاطلسي اس اس 29 هي
منظومه استراتيجيه مزوده بالصواريخ
باليستيا عابره للقارات هذه الصواريخ
مجهزه برؤوس نوويه حراريه تعمل بالوقود
الصلب وكلمه يارس بالروسيه هي اختصار
لصاروخ الرضع النووي اغلب خصائص تلك
المنظومه التقنيه التي دخلت الخدمه لاول
مره في عام 2010 لا تزال السريه غير انها
تعد الاكثر تطورا بعد صواريخ سارمات وجاءت
كتعديل محدث لصواريخ حيث يبلغ طول صاروخ
يارس 23 مترا وقطر قدره مترا والوزن عند
الاطلاق يبلغ 46 طنا بسرعه تتعدى سرعه
الصوت اربعه عشره مره يصل مدى صاروخ يارس
الى 12 الف كيلو متر قادر على اصابه اي
هدف على سطح الارض صواريخ يارس تسير على
هيكل مكون من سته عشره عجله حيث ان
الصاروخ الواحد يمكن ان يحمل سته رؤوس
نوويه بقوه تتراوح بين 150
تمتلك خاصيه استهداف منفصله اضافه لمدى
الصاروخ تعتبر خاصيته الفرط صوتيه اهم
مميزاته القدره التفجيريه الاجماليه
للرؤوس النوويه التي يحملها صاروخ يارس
يمكنها ان تعادل مليون طن وهنا يجب
الاشاره الى ان الصاروخ يعتمد على نظام
جلونا الروسي المعادلي لنظام جي بي اس
الامريكي تمتلك روسيا ما يزيد عن 147
صاروخا من هذا النوع بما فيها
135 منصه متحركه و12 منصه ثابته واشنطن
فسرت فسرت تطوير موسكو لهذا النوع من
الصواريخ بالالتفاف على معاهده ستارت التي
تقيد اعداد صواريخ توبول لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات